well the backlash against sexual
harassment is broadening in scope for
about the 15th time now and it's now
hitting Marvel Comics legend Stanley
he's 95 years old and at that age he
needs nurses to care for him at his home
and now some of those nurses have
accused him of groping them and asking
for sexual favors sexual harassment is
appalling of course the other hand this
is a man who is already 50 was 50 years
old when the term sexual harassment was
first coined target a helpless elderly
man like that does seem like preying on
the weak not protecting them so what are
we to make of this Ashleigh Pratt is a
contributor to u.s. News World Report
and she joins us tonight actually thanks
coming up thanks for having me Tucker
this is one of those rare cases where
and I don't know the truth of it and I
want to pretend that I do but it
wouldn't surprise me if it were true
because the elderly for a bunch of
physical reasons sometimes do say
inappropriate things related to sex I
mean they do this is actually a
well-known phenomenon and I think most
nurses who care for the elderly are very
aware of this so given that it seems a
little strange to hear charges again
this presents it as charges against a
guy what it's actually kind of common
well at the same time though we have to
you know take this a little seriously
and realize that when these allegations
are coming out there needs to be an
investigative process to them we can't
just go out there defaming people and I
think that that's one of the biggest
issues that I have currently with the
me2 movement it's doing a lot of great
things but it's also allowing a platform
for defamation to happen and in this
case you know if these allegations are
true then it should be brought in a
legal suit and then these should be
examined for what they are and if he was
groping people and he was exposing
himself in doing all of these things
that they're alleging then of course
that is despicable behavior but if in
fact you know it's just jokes and
whatnot that we can we can determine
what those you know issues are there but
I'm I'm someone who I worked on a
campaign with all men multiple times and
I know jokes versus inappropriate
behavior and I think we need to trust
women in these instances and realize
that we know what is right and we know
what is wrong but in this case of
defamation that is an issue what if
there's a third explanation which and
again I don't know the truth but having
been around
the elderly and I think anyone who has
knows exactly what I'm talking about
what if they're true but a symptom of
advanced age this is not uncommon so is
there an age at which maybe it's 95
where we say you're not fully
responsible for the way you're behaving
you don't represent all men maybe you're
just 95 years old and you do things you
wouldn't have done when you were 75 or
55 right but we can't make excuses for
behavior if he's exposing himself in
asking for sexual favors you know and
that right there is a problem it's not
just jokes like when they came out with
the allegations against George HW Bush
that bothered me because those were
jokes that were being made in front of
his wife now you can have an argument
there whether or not he should be making
them but it's just jokes in this
situation if he was actually exposing
himself and groping women who were
taking care of him that is a problem
that you can't blame on old age if he's
making jokes that they don't you can't
but that's a thing that is a behavioral
issue that we should not tolerate as
women or as men and that is my problem
I'm totally opposed to it except there
are cases well I'm sure I'll be killed
for saying this because everyone's
required to lie all the time I'm Erica
right now but again that is sometimes a
symptom of age and I you know I don't
know what I think I should probably stop
talking I guess actually thank you for
joining us thank you Tucker